show me the future
he's the man that killed my mother I
know what you're thinking Dave we need
your help hi ray I know Barry's the
flash
I love you take your last breath you're
the change the past unless a
this is my head freaky what do dr. wells
and the reverse-flash have to do with
each other they're the same person
anybody that knows about this is in a
hell of a lot of danger and warned you
not to mess with the timeline hello
Cisco I don't know anything anymore
especially who I can and can't trust the
real endgame is almost here then face me
now there you don't make me do this I
promise you Barry Allen it will die
my mom's killer is still out there you
had your suspicions about Wells from the
very beginning you had thought that he
might be the man in yellow except the
blood from her house didn't match him
one close closer than I've ever been
he's been patient well not every
criminal i sat in the dark berry doing
all right he seems cranky you think dr.
wells killed Barry's mom I don't know
yet but I do know that Wells keeps
secrets I know what you're thinking tell
you wells isn't who he says he is after
that day Harrison wells became a
completely different person who are you
my name is your board forum hey
youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna be
a breakdown of a WTF finale trailer they
just posted after this episode of the
flash just careful for spoilers in case
you guys don't want to know anything
about the final episodes of the flash
because most of this most of this is
like right up to episode 23 so here we
go biggest thing Ra's al yes Stephen
Amell is wearing League of Assassins
gear I know you guys have been sending
me that picture all week and the reason
I haven't done anything about it is
because it's been super spoilery so I
was waiting for it to show up in the
trailer so here it is so we can talk our
faces off about it now biggest thing
team up between the flash arrow and
firestorm or raza Mel however you want
to think about him I didn't seem in the
trailer but the Rogues are rumored for
the finale to in some way maybe not
every single rogue but some of them I
know a lot of you asking questions about
how time travel figures into Oliver
becoming rachele cool and if it's going
to be part of the flash plot it's
totally possible but I think most of
those questions are going to be answered
on arrow it sounds like what's going to
be happening is is during like broken
arrow Oliver is going to find a reason a
compelling reason to become ratio goal I
think the timeline that we saw in the
flash with team flash in that special
chamber where Cisco got killed by the
reverse-flash he's the normal timeline
so I don't think there's going to be any
like crazy wonky changing of the past
I'm still expecting Oliver to be the
arrow by the start of season 4 but I
think they're going to have some fun
with the idea of Ra's al the fun thing
too is that Amanda page shows up in the
trailer along with emily kinney they
both work at mercury labs she's like the
harrison wells of mercury labs i know
there's a lot of Harrison wells stuff
that we have to talk about from this
episode tonight but I'm gonna do most of
that in that video don't worry it's
fully explainable seriously there's
gonna be so much awesome stuff in the
next couple of episodes including
Gorilla Grodd I know they're a lot of
questions about the spinoff series in
like how these finales have a flash and
arrow finales are going to tie into it I
think they will set that up even though
it's a midseason show I'll talk about it
more as it plays out on arrow but I
think that we'll find out how caity lotz
is coming back in the arrow finale
whether it be cloned completely new
character or if she's just like an AI
consciousness of some kind like a Gideon
computer type consciousness I don't
think that's the case though I think
she's going to be a physical person I
know there's a lot of footage of the
atom
cross over to that's episode 18 of the
flash next week the weird thing is is
because the episodes are out of sync err
on the flash are out of sync tomorrow's
episode of arrow is actually happening
after episode 18 of the flash so they'll
actually go back in time it's going to
be completely messed up so I'll try to
explain it whenever I post my arrow
video tomorrow night be sure to
subscribe to get that and my next video
is going to be the flash episode video
whole bunch of a 0 bars on stuff to talk
about is gonna be a lot of fun really
mark hamill my new favorite guest star
ever he actually he said he wanted to
play Clayface too so he could totally go
on Gotham now I'll be talking about all
that stuff in just a sec so why you guys
wait for that you can click here for all
my flash videos and you can click here
to learn all about the spin-off series
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys in just a sec everybody let's
high five
you